it wasn't very fun to make there were
some personalities pink denies Throwing
Shade at Christina Aguilera after
criticizing the vibe on the Lady
Marmalade music video set
[Music]
during an interview with BuzzFeed UK
pink was asked to rank her 12 most
iconic music videos Lady Marmalade the
grammy-winning collab featuring Pink
Christina Maya and Lil Kim was ranked
last yeah number 12 out of 12. there's
Lady Marmalade I'm gonna put that down
here at 12. it wasn't very fun to make
I'm all about fun and it was like a lot
of fuss and
there were some personalities
um Kim and Maya were nice it didn't take
long for that response to go viral with
some people suggesting it was a not so
subtle dig at Christina but over the
weekend pink shut down the speculation
on Twitter writing in part y'all are
nuts Christina had to do with who was on
that song If you don't know by now I'm
not shading someone by telling it over
and over and over what actually happened
the Grammy winner added that she has no
interest in the drama and she's a little
busy right now selling tickets and
albums I want my kids to see what it
looks like
to have a mom that's a boss to wrap it
all up pink referenced a kiss she and
Christina once shared during a game of
spin the bottle a kiss Christina dished
about on Watch What Happens live with
Andy Cohen back in 2019. I was excited
about a kiss and like I was like oh a
kiss and you know like all all's good
maybe no you know whatever and then she
said she put her hand up like this I was
like oh okay that's what we're doing
pink put it bluntly I kissed Christina's
mouth I don't need to kiss her
I like to be really really honest of
course fans of pink and Christina know
the two have publicly feuded and made up
during a 2009 episode of VH1's Behind
the Music pink claimed she had to
challenge a record executive about what
part of Lady Marmalade she got to sing
what's the high part what's the most
singing part Christine is going to take
that part and I stood up and I said Hi
how are you so nice of you to introduce
yourself I'm pink she will not be taking
that part I think that's what the
meeting's about
and I know she had some you know
feelings or whatever about how the
recording of Lady marmala went down and
all that and she was a little heckling
me in in the audience a little bit
behind the director I was like
going on right Flash Forward to 2016.
Pink and Christina made nice teaming up
on The Voice pink serving as a mentor
for Christina's team I hadn't seen her
in years and years and years and we grew
we became moms we grew up and
we hugged it out and pink echoed all
that during a chat with E.T her and I
have had history and it had hasn't
always been wonderful but
finally I think it just took us 15 years
and I feel like there was true love and
it felt really good in all honesty I'm a
fan of hers as for Christina she told
Andy Cohen she's a fan of Pinks too
she's a different person now she's like
a mom she's like she's cool there you
have it folks there's no beef here but
there is one legendary music video
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah